[Applause]
bring car Kelly
[Applause]
ah hi welcome to G live I'm selfish lazy
Bryn cartelli joins us today
congratulations so much
we are giggling at that little squeak
that she made camera when she was
announced what happened well when I they
didn't show it exact even when i when i
found out i wanna britain gave me a huge
hug and be like picked me up and squeeze
me so hard I was like oh gosh I love it
live television folks yeah so speaking
of being live we are live with you right
now so please send in your questions hit
the comments we will try to get to as
many as we can in the meantime take me
back to that moment Bryn what was going
through your mind when you're standing
there waiting for Carson to say the name
okay it was it was really nerve-racking
stay in there I didn't I mean I was I
was really happy for Britain and I was
like oh my gosh either way I'm so so
happy and I didn't expect to win I
thought I thought he was gonna take home
I was like I was so happy for him I'm so
excited for him and I still AM he's
gonna kill it
but when it happened I was just like oh
okay like this is real like this is
really gonna happen like this is gonna
turn into something and I was I was more
than excited obviously
yeah I'm not gonna lie though I think a
lot of people did see you as a
front-runner in this competition you
know no disrespect because everybody is
so talented on the show but I do think
when it came down to the finale a lot of
people predicted you know when was there
ever a moment where you thought like oh
I might have this in the bag honestly
like I'm not even just saying this to
say it but I never thought I was going
to win until I heard my name called
really I never I was like I I thought I
was like maybe I'll make it far but I
never thought I was going to win
didn't Kelly tell you like you're gonna
win girl yeah I didn't I was I gonna say
that I believe okay so how are you
feeling today did you get any sleep last
night I got four hours of sleep better
than zero that didn't tear I got a
little bit it's gonna it's not a crazy
day already and I'm just ready for it
I'm ready for it all to happen and I'm
excited yeah
has it sunk in no what's happening I'm
not crying so it's not like really
sinking in right now that's okay now
what was the highlight of last night for
you was it actually getting the trophy
was it singing with Julia was it
something off
camera Oh mmm that's a good question
there was a lot last last night was just
it was a really emotional night just
because it was the last night of being
on set and being with all those people
in the backs everyone backstage and hair
and makeup and wardrobe and everything
but I would say definitely probably
winning was a really probably the best
part but singing with Julia was really
really cool and she's an awesome person
and I love that talk to me about Julia a
little bit and and that moment how
special was that to share the stage with
her oh man she wrote she was the one
that co-wrote my original song so we had
something to talk about we were we
immediately bonded and I'm a songwriter
too I just write different styles than
she does I have a more I read more
stories and she writes the like awesome
catchy everything everyone's gonna love
it song like that's what she writes and
she's extremely talented and so the fact
I got to sing with her and talk to her
about that I was a little nervous
because I was like I didn't know I know
Kelly's amazing I know not everyone is
as awesome as Kelly and she was just
like so kind and really funny and
immediately when we got when we got up
on stage to rehearse she was like it
seems like I've been friends with her
for a really long time so it was she was
like do your thing I'm just here to
support you and I really like that and
she was amazing did she give you any
intel into her mindset during the
songwriting for your single did you guys
talk about your single specifically at
all we did a little bit she was she was
just really excited that I was able to
sing it and I was talking to her I was
like I listened to the demo that she
sent to Kelly originally I'm like I hope
you don't mind I ain't like I changed it
because I've not really been in the
business so I know that people change
like the demos that they get and I was
like I hope you don't mind and she's
like oh my gosh girl people do that all
the time I was like oh thank God because
I changed a lot of the things in it and
just the melodies and things that I
wanted to make more me and but I mean
gosh they could have released that demo
under her name and it would have charted
all the everything and it would have
been everywhere but I'm really still
doing very well it's doing amazing so
tell me what the next year looks like
for you I know you're still in high
school so are you gonna go back to
school are you gonna switch to
homeschooling I wish I knew
okay I don't really know what's gonna
happen it's a little scary honestly but
I'm I'm just I want to do school as much
as I can and I don't know what that's
gonna look like whether it's at my
public high school back in Longmeadow or
if it's online or if it's home I don't
know what it's gonna be but I want to do
school I'm really passionate about that
and I but music is in the forefront now
and I'm and that's what I'm committed to
and that's what I'm gonna stay with and
I thought about it they were talking
Kelly and her husband were attacking me
like is this what you really want to do
and I was thinking about it and I was
like I mean that's a loaded question you
know like because there's a lot of
things that can happen and you never
know and I was and I thought back and
I'm and I remember walking out of the
studio recording my original song walk
my way and I after that whole thing
laying down all the background vocals
and myself and having all these ideas
and just the energy that it was a song
that no one had heard yet and I knew
that people were gonna love it so I was
just it was amazing and I I just loved
every second of it and if I walked out
and I was like if there's any doubt that
I wanted to do this before it was all it
was all gone and so I was I was like
yeah this is what I want to do I think
what did Kelly call you yesterday during
the press conference like a lion out oh
yeah super focus she said that should be
the name of your debut album yeah that
was actually good idea I know hang on to
that one so what does the debut album
look like for you what do you think and
when do you start the ball rolling on
that I want to start it soon as soon as
possible but I I want my album to be
dark pop kind of like a trying to think
people so that like people understand
what I'm going for but like a sia mixed
with like dual eepa and like throwing in
some random ones here but alan stone
like that awesome storytelling really
cool soulful energy that's just
ridiculous mixed with all these current
pop singers you know like that's what I
want like I want to find the middle and
I feel like no I mean there's there are
a lot of unique artists out there but
this is my own lane and that's what I
want to do pop glory I love it
so let's talk about Kelly a little bit
and your experience with her I mean she
has been so involved
I feel like this season she's been a
really hands-on coach what have you kind
of taken from that experience with her
people though I mean you see how
hands-on she is on camera and you
underst
dan that but she is more like we text
all the time because she's always like
great I got that ATS out a little bit
she's like a million things that she's
always saying and she's really really
open and to new ideas and really honest
with me and is so in touch about
everything that's gonna happen and she
she just wants me to be happy she's not
she's not controlling she's not
overstepping it's just it makes me
comfortable and it's it's good to know
that I have her behind me and this whole
process in this whole industry how
involved has she said she'll be in your
career she's made it very clear she's
gonna definitely be very involved yeah
like do you think in a managerial role
or you know helping you pick song I mean
definitely as like as a good friend and
as a helper with connections and finding
people and and her husband's manager and
she's an amazing team that all but I'm
really close with now and they're just
they're really really special and I love
them all if she takes a page out of the
Blake Shelton handbook I would say maybe
a touring mate that would be cool right
I would love that
now Kelly is returning as a coach again
next season so for anybody who is out
there thinking about auditioning for
next season what is your pitch for Kelly
why should they choose to be on Team
Kelly oh my gosh are you kidding okay
Kelly is the best coach that I think the
voice has ever had and that's not that's
not just because I'm I mean I'm a little
biased but it's not just because I'm on
her team and she's really if you wanna
coach that's gonna support all of your
ideas and give you honest feedback and
want you to succeed and want to be
involved in that and even afterwards go
with Kelly I mean that's just the she's
amazing and she'll do any shine right
you want I mean you read Caleb and Dr
was with me in the top 12 and they dr is
like rock soul and Caleb's country and
I'm like okay like this is she's amazing
and she worked she knows a billion songs
she knows what it's like to be in this
process she just understands what we're
feeling and is so down to earth and it's
it's she's the best amazing now you've
said that at you're a songwriter you've
said that you've written some songs
about your experience on the voice over
the last few months can you tell me
about what moments inspired you and what
those songs are like yeah I mean there's
been I've had a lot of friendships out
here and I've made a lot of close
friends and it's a
a lot about that and just writing in
characters and writing and watching
other friendships form and watching it
all pieced together and I definitely I
remember there was one specific song I
wrote and it was about I was in an
executive audition and I heard sound so
and I just something I think I take
things that I over dramatis eyes them I
think that's what all song writers do
but it was like we were it was on the
fence of me even moving on it was like
it was a decision we had to make like I
was able to move on but I had there was
things I'd sacrifice to go on to this
next round and in the in the earlier
process before we started filming and I
was like I don't know if I want to do
that I I was not sure if I wanted to do
it and then we thought about for a while
I was like I want to do it now and then
people are like no you're not gonna do
it and so it almost it almost ended for
me just like that based off a decision
being scared and wanting to protect me
and which it was like a lack of wanting
to take a risk and I just I was like it
was not a mad song but it was like let
me do this let me try it was all about I
I want to try give me this next I want
to try this and it's called save me the
next dance so I'm hoping that I can I
turn it into a love song somehow like it
kind of turned into that I love it but I
definitely I want to I want to put that
out as soon as I can and I just want to
I have a lot of music that I want to put
out and or just get other writers to
collaborate with me on because I mean
I'm 15 I can't I mean I haven't lived
all these lives to understand everything
and I'm and I want to learn more about
writing and hey Jackie Foster's friends
who was on the season Jackie's friends
with Danielle Bradbery a while ago and
she talked to her about her experience
after and she was like Danielle learned
she was a writer before but she got so
much better after seeing being in this
process and she's like I'm that's why
Jackie was coming up she's coming up
last night she's like I'm excited for
you because I know that your writing
it's already amazing and it's just gonna
she's like I'm just excited to see what
happens to it and that made me excited
and I hope that whenever I want to get
the chance to talk to Danielle I
remember I can just because that that
makes me really that makes me feel
really excited just to work with people
and just get better and better it it's
so hard to write when I'm in this
process I can't write because we're on a
schedule like this and we're just in
this loop of everything and it's it's
amazing and I love every step of the
press
I just can't write a song when I'm here
and it's I just when I get home like
when we recorded battles and knockouts
those are pre-recorded and then we were
home for a little while before coming
out I wrote like 10 songs I was like but
once I'm home they all come out so I'm
so excited to go home and write it all
down
when do you get to go home Saturday
Saturday and what else are you excited
about in terms of getting back all the
junk food
there's like I live on my town I live in
a suburban town but we're surrounded by
like farm towns and they have really
good ice cream shops like from
freshening the cows and it's like so
good and I just want to go and eat it
all now are you've done with school for
the like do you go home and it's summer
for you or do you have to go back to
school oh I have to go back to school we
do it's gonna be it's mean I love school
for the most part it really does inspire
me a lot just to watch people I'm such a
people watcher it's kind of creepy but I
like to it really helps inspire me as a
musician and I like to learn i love to
dive into things and get involved but at
the same time it's a lot when you're
trying to balance all this it's a lot a
lot of people don't understand that and
they just think oh she could do better
she could do better balance ago I'm like
I'm trying my god you have a lot on your
plate
let's cut bring some slack everybody if
they've been so supportive my school has
all my teachers I've been in contact
with and they've they've been like more
than I've ever thought that they would
be they've been in really close contact
with me they've supported me they've
been like listen if when you want to get
this done get it done if you can't we'll
get it done eventually and it's it's
it's a little stressful knowing that I
do have to get it done at some point
right but it's nice that it's no rush
and it's just I'm gonna get it done when
I can and I want it because I want to
graduate I want it I want to go to
college if I can and I just I I wanted I
love school so I want to do it as long
as I can you know who did that very well
off of the idle train with Scotty
McCreery yeah he was 17 I think yeah he
would and he went to college and did the
whole thing have any alumni of any
besides Kelly of course reached out to
you with any words of advice yeah I was
I'm closed a lot of people from season
13
so I talked Chloe was there yesterday
and so we were getting our makeup and
hair done together so we were talking
about it and I'm really close friends
with Addison and Brooke and red Marlo
and so they've all been texting me and
it's it's been really cool and there's a
lot of people from season 13 I was
friends with so it's been really really
cool to have them reach out and I've
been talking to them and people even
from I mean they didn't even air its
people from blinds of this season who
either they're blind audition didn't air
because there's a lot of people that go
into that process and our reaching out
and I was really close friends with some
of them and they're like Bryn you did it
and I was like it's so weird and the
fact that it was Britton and I in the
last two was really cool because he was
the first person I met for this whole
experience like Wow he was we were in
the airport on the way to the executive
audition not even The Blind Auditions
was before that and I was like hi I'm
Brandon yeah I was like and and we were
so quiet and now we get like a little
bit we could talk all day long I love
you must have made some incredible
friendships on this journey I can only
imagine yeah yeah thank you so much for
being here I love you I'm excited to see
everything that you are doing and I hope
to have you come back and see us again
when the next season starts rolling
around and get an update from you of
course thank you guys so much for
watching
congratulations to Bryn and the next
season will be here before we know it so
get ready for that we'll see you soon
bye guys bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]